كان الرئيس ترامب جالسًا في البيت الأبيض
لأكثر من ثلاث ساعات
يشاهد التلفاز بينما تكشّف الهجوم المميت على
مبنى الكابيتول ، هل أنت على علم بأي
مكالمة هاتفية من رئيس
الولايات المتحدة إلى وزير
الدفاع في ذلك اليوم لا أعرف  من
المذكرة
هل أنت على علم بأي مكالمة هاتفية من قبل
رئيس الولايات المتحدة إلى
المدعي العام للولايات المتحدة في
ذلك اليوم
لا علم بأي مكالمة هاتفية من قبل
رئيس الولايات المتحدة إلى
وزير الأمن الداخلي في ذلك
اليوم.  لست على دراية بهذا
ترامب الآن الرافض لمناشدات أعضاء
الكونغرس ومساعديه وأفراد أسرته
لإخبار حشد من
أنصاره بالعودة إلى ديارهم إذا كهف بنس
سنجر الأم عبر
الشوارع بدلاً من تأجيج التوترات
بما في ذلك مهاجمة تغريدة  نائب
الرئيس مايك بنس ، بدت التغريدة
لي وكأنها عكس
ما كنا بحاجة إليه حقًا في تلك اللحظة
والذي كان بمثابة وقف للتصعيد ، حيث كان
يعطي الضوء الأخضر
لهؤلاء الأشخاص.
كان التليفزيون ترامب على الهاتف مع
محاميه رودي جولياني الذي كان بدوره
يدفع أعضاء مجلس الشيوخ لإبطاء
التصديق على فوز جو بايدن في
محاولة دائمة للبقاء في السلطة حيث
ذهب ترامب إلى مقر الإقامة في تلك
الليلة ولم يعرب عن مخاوفه بشأن
الهجوم  بدلاً من ذلك ، قال فقط اقتبس من
مايك بنس خذلني لكن اللجنة
كشفت أن تصرفات ترامب
تهدد حياة بنس
للاتصالات اللاسلكية من نائب الرئيس
تفاصيل الخدمة السرية تظهر الفوضى مع
مثيري الشغب على بعد أقدام فقط
الآن سعداء إذا
فقدنا أي المزيد من الوقت قد يكون لدينا
نفقد القدرة
على المغادرة ، لذلك إذا كنا سنغادر ، فنحن
بحاجة إلى القيام بذلك الآن
، فقد تمكنوا من الوصول إلى الطابق الثاني
ولدي الجمهور على بعد خمسة
أقدام مني هنا أدناه وهذه
الشهادة من البيت الأبيض
مسؤول أمني تم الاحتفاظ بهويته
مجهولة من أجل سلامته ، بدأ
أفراد vpt tell في هذا الوقت
يخشون على حياتهم الخاصة ، كانت هناك
مكالمات لتوديع أفراد الأسرة
حتى  في اليوم التالي للهجوم الذي
أظهره خطاب ترامب ، رفض القول إن
الانتخابات قد انتهت ، لكن هذه
الانتخابات انتهت الآن ،
وقد صدق الكونجرس على النتائج التي
لا أريد أن أقولها ،
لكني أريد فقط أن أقول إن
الكونجرس قد صدق على النتائج
دون القول بأن الانتخابات قد انتهت
، تخطط اللجنة لإجراء مقابلات مع الشهود
خلف الأبواب المغلقة في أغسطس ، ثم
المزيد من الجلسات العامة في سبتمبر ،
يعتقد بعض الأعضاء أنهم طرحوا
قضية جنائية ضد الرئيس السابق ،
وأعتقد أن الرئيس لديه بالتأكيد كشف
جنائي
الآن.  الأشياء التي ستحاول اللجنة
اكتشافها خلال أغسطس
هي القصة وراء تلك النصوص المفقودة
من 5 يناير و 6 يناير من 2000
إلى 2021 الآن تؤكد المخابرات أن
هناك نوعًا من ترحيل الهاتف
أدى إلى فقدان بعض هذه
لكن اللجنة تقول إنهم
مصممون على اكتشاف القصة الحقيقية
وراء ذلك ، أخبرني جيمي راسكين أحد أعضاء
اللجنة أنهم  سنقوم
بملء مجموعة كاملة من الخيوط حول
ثغرات أغسطس في سطر القصة
بالإضافة إلى تلك النصوص وقال اقتباس
أننا سنكتشف هذا اللغز بأكمله من
خلال نصوص الخدمة السرية
Manu Raju cnn capitol hill